hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm frances
foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a very very very special
a live interview with douglas murray
featuring a q a
it is uh we have so much to talk about
with douglas today just to give you an
overview of how the show is going to go
we're going to interview douglas for
about 50 minutes to an hour
then we're gonna have a very short break
and then we will go to the q a
if you want to ask a question or for us
to ask you a question
the two options you can either send us a
super chat and our producer will pick it
up and give it to us
or you can use the paypal link which is
in the pinned comment as well
and without any further ado we're not
even going to bother setting the context
you all know what this is about and
you'll know who douglas murray is there
he is douglas welcome to the show
it's great to be back with you guys i'm
not going to lie douglas we did consider
calling this episode of trigonometry
hello douglas my old friend
because it has been a rather dark few
days
uh and let's start with january the
sixth uh you've written about it but i
think
it's an important moment not only in
modern history but you know in the
entire history or perhaps democracy will
never know
how big it is going to turn out what did
you make of what happened in the capital
yes i was covering the u.s election uh
and was in the u.s for about five weeks
ahead of the november election i was in
washington dc on election night and
wrote from there
and left a few days later when it became
clear that uh events were gonna sort of
rumble on
and that although it seemed pretty clear
i think it was clear from fairly early
on in the night that donald trump had
lost the election
it seemed clear that there were a set of
legal challenges and others that would
have to play themselves out
and that nothing was going to happen for
some time
but of course in that period since
since the night of the election in
november uh
donald trump obviously did continue to
make
the same assertions that he had on the
night of the election
he think as i wrote in a number of
places i think
he said fallaciously that he had
won the election and the onus was on him
and his legal team to prove
that he had won the election and they
couldn't prove it they didn't
and by the way i think it is worth
remembering that
the various different strata of the
american government
and the legislative process worked uh
there were a number of
uh right-wing conservative figures you
might say who
were saying i thought slightly
sinisterly after the election
well when this goes to the supreme court
you know then then it'll become clear
and then we can have trump as having one
well
actually they did go to the supreme
court and supreme court chucked out the
applications from trump's
legal teams and that happened uh in
other jurisdictions as well as state
levels
and it was clear that donald trump's
assertion
was not able to be proved uh i said
repeatedly that seemed to be the case
that
even if there were instances of voter
fraud and voter suppression
much of which isn't particularly new in
american politics but
could well have happened in a more rife
way this year than before
nevertheless uh he did not prove that it
had happened to such an extent that he
had in fact won the election
joe biden hadn't and i thought once more
by the way that the claims that were
made by the trump supporters
uh uh became more and more uh
tenuous people said things like i i've
i've said this to a number of of a
number of
as it were pro-trump platforms
that when people said things like there
was something that didn't quite
feel right on the night of the election
yeah our guy was winning
and then it then he suddenly was losing
and they were saying this as if that's
unheard of
and i kept on saying obviously to the
bemusement of most americans
but sunderland um
you know the right metaphor to explain
things to americans
and they just kept saying why does he
keep shouting sunderland at us
but of course all the british viewers
know this is the night on the 2016
brexit referendum when it seemed that
romaine had been
winning and then suddenly the vote came
in from sunderland and
and the whole night changed course you
know that's what happens with elections
uh i think all of us can remember
election nights when we thought it was
going to go one when it's gone another
uh so there was nothing so the specifics
weren't proven
by trump and his people and the
generalities became more and more
tenuous
and then we get to this stage where it
seems that trump has his sort of
last uh um well all the doors have been
closing to him hadn't they
uh as the the days and weeks have gone
on since november
all the doors have been closing and uh
congress was going to vote to confirm
the
win for joe biden and uh on that day
you know trump calls on supporters uh to
mass in washington and to
protest against this basically to to uh
he says stop the steal this is one of
his slogans but
again i mean repeat that
if if the election had been stolen to
such an extent
that it was donald trump who won it not
joe biden then it was incumbent upon
donald trump and his legal team to prove
that and they didn't
and so there was something not just
irresponsible but reckless
in calling for people uh to gather to
protest
something which was not true
i don't want to delve into trying to
understand the minds of any person
who i don't know but i suppose it'll be
up to historians to try to work out
in the future whether donald trump
himself actually believes this at this
stage or not
nevertheless he encouraged people to
amass
and although as is always has to be
stressed
the majority of protesters were peaceful
and seem to be decent law-abiding
americans a number of people turned up a
large number of people
uh turned up who certainly weren't and
uh i think that there's gonna be a very
interesting thing i wrote from the
spectator the other day it's gonna be
very
question of the extent to which one can
directly
claim that the president was liable for
what happened
on the capitol because
his speech i thought in the run-up to it
uh
was um i wouldn't say it was incitement
but it was certainly uh highly
inflammatory
and does raise the whole question
which i think should be on the minds of
everybody of every political side
it should have been for some time now
it's not like we should have been
starting from scratch
the very interesting question of who
exactly bears responsibility for what
once you raise a crowd i mean it's
what some of us always worry about with
with crowds of any size for any
purpose i think i've said to you before
how much i myself dislike
them uh precisely because you never know
about it didn't you douglas i did and i
i i i
worry i've always worried about that so
i've seen it in so many different
contexts of
what happens when large numbers of
people come out and you get
sincere and serious people as you did
for instance in the blm protests last
summer and you also get very insincere
people
and you get gadflies and weirdos and
that's
the best uh uh in the bad part of the
scenario and the worst part
is you get the sort of people who are
willing to turn
violent and then you see seems like we
saw the capital and uh you know the the
extraordinary and terrible side of you
know i mean a woman
a youngish woman being shot uh uh um
for what exactly it's it's uh it's a
very should be a sanitary
uh moment for everyone but i think that
for
um the president and his his team and
the people around him who goaded on this
particular
claim it's not surprising to me i think
that it was so solitary that the
president
finally conceded you know it's very
interesting that that happened
finally i mean we've been waiting for a
concession speech
uh how tragic it is for america and in
fact and of course
on much less important scale how tragic
it is for donald trump's legacy
uh where there were some things he
achieved in his presidency
it's terrible for the legacy that he uh
should have
it should have needed effectively
an appalling uh um break-in
of a capital um and uh the death
of a number of people to persuade him to
finally do what he should have done
around about the sixth the seventh of
november uh
so i think it's uh it's been a
very concerning period um but it's one
we
you know that i think everybody should
learn from douglas
are calls for him to be impeached do you
agree with that do you think he should
be
no i mean we'll see if people can come
up with evidence that he should be i
suppose uh
that'll be i have no particularly strong
views on that uh i think impeachment is
a word it's been bandied around so often
in american politics and in every
direction
i i in a way i think
one of the things that's most important
i'm not an american myself although i've
spent a fair amount of my life in
america and
have a great admiration for the country
and for the the culture of the country
uh i think it's just as an
observer as it were as a friend of the
country i'd say that
i think it's very important that in the
same way as it was important that that
silly you know sort of uh chant of lock
her up about hillary clinton
didn't actually lead to hillary clinton
being locked up
you know or sort of put on trial or
something so i think it's important that
in victory the democrats don't
go for something like impeachment just
as by the way as i think it would have
been
unwise had the republican again
no politically it would have been
opportunistic and clever
but it would have been morally unwise
and unwise for the health of the nation
if republicans had held on to the senate
and congress for instance
and then pushed on with an attempted
impeachment of joe biden
over family business you know what i'm
saying here is i i
think anybody who is an american anyone
who's a friend of america
wants to work out how america can be
walked back from this
brink and everything that involves terms
like impeachment imprisonment
prosecution and much more of any
of the two major candidates in a
presidential race seems to me to be a
very unwise
uh position to get into because
it's going to exacerbate it's going to
make people dig down
uh so i myself would think that any of
these moves would be unwise
uh douglas let me ask you this you
mentioned the word responsibility you
talked about liability
and we had brett weinstein who's a
friend of both of ours on the show
uh talking about these things from a
left-wing perspective but let me put a
question that might make
people on the right yourself perhaps
included uncomfortable which is
you talk about the locker up uh
is there a degree of responsibility to
take for many people on the right
who did not take donald trump seriously
when he said i'm gonna lock up my
opponent and
are they now culpable to some extent for
what has happened for the lives that
have been lost for the huge damage
that's been done to the democratic
process
in america should think about that i
think it is something they're thinking
about i think i've been thinking about
it for more than four years
uh i i said when
um when i was in america recently that
uh something very strange that happened
i think i actually said this to brett
that i noticed that with the perhaps
exception of brett and his wife
uh and maybe i should say some other
american friends
the number of dinner tables almost every
dinner table you sat down
to an america if there were people from
both different parties where they just
couldn't converse anymore
and they just couldn't talk to each
other and i kept wondering why it wasn't
am i is it where my steel man version of
it
was and i think it's fairly accurate
the the democrats my democrat friends in
america couldn't forgive the republicans
for allowing donald trump to happen
um and and i think there's obviously
a fair amount in there i mean and i
think it's something the republican
party had been thinking about i mean
it's not like
he was the preferred candidate of the
party in
2016. um
i i also think that uh
to an enormous extent people did see
some of this coming
i don't think people saw exactly what
was going to happen
but um take this one for instance
and again i read about this recently um
why was it always the case
that although there were some good
people who worked for donald trump
particularly foreign policy areas and
trade negotiations and much more
why was it that he did seem always to
have such trouble filling positions
um why from the get-go i mean i say this
having you know i mean
friends in previous administrations
democrat and republican
why why did my republican friends so
many of them
not accept uh jobs with donald trump's
administration from the get-go
and it was always pretty much the same
reason which was that people
just didn't trust that he wasn't going
to pull some crap
at some point that was going to sully
everyone who'd been anywhere near it
and i i think that is that has been a
serious
uh consideration i think that there have
been there were of course there were the
never trump
movement um i wrote uh
not long ago that the question that will
always
or even before recent events that will
halt the never trump movement will be
whether there were things that they
could have done
in the administration that would be um
effective i think people like elliot
abrams who was venezuela representative
of the president and lastly represented
the administration
on iran policy a very distinguished
foreign policy figure
did a lot of good uh um in his work
on venezuela and iran and would it if
if more people have gone in would there
have been more good
uh yes possibly but now we will see even
more clearly what the downside would
have been which was that
people would be contaminated with a
president whose exit from office
makes that of richard nixon look
positively graceful
and and that that is the problem but i
mean
i i think that the i think the questions
around donald trump were pretty much all
answered in 2016
for the for the for the right uh which
was
you know could they keep him out no um
did some of the some of the right want
to obviously
others made their piece
with him
a you know better to
to have this person than the alternative
and and that's
that's something i think everybody is
going to be continuing to weigh up
i myself could never
understand i mean i have on a number of
occasions written
about aspects
of his policy praise i think that peace
deals uh in the middle east
that he negotiated deserve praise i
think that he's
he was uh the first major figure in the
democratic world to recognize the threat
that in the 21st century poses and to
try to do something about that
uh but again you know you weigh that up
against the rest of the legacy and it is
it's possible that the that all of that
and much more will be forgotten
amid these scenes and
and i'd add people particularly on the
activists left who will want
everything else to be forgotten and will
use the horrible events of the other day
um
as a demonstration that uh that there's
nothing
uh good to be said about not just donald
trump the republican party
the conservative side the right and so
on
but douglas let me just follow up
quickly before francis jumps in
uh the counter-argument to my
counter-argument which
which i asked you about the right
responsibility would be
that in 2016 only a non-system candidate
like donald trump could have won
only someone who promised to quote
unquote drain the swamp
only someone who addressed the issues
that the republican
not the standard discourse in the
republican party ignored
only a man or a woman like that could
have broken that deadlock
could have got through the concerns of
ordinary voters and for that reasons
uh for that for those reasons even this
price
was worth paying
yes there will be people who will say
that
um this this
this is a very tricky one isn't it
because it's impossible not to
reinterpret events in light of what's
what what's happened
since um the republican party
by 26 become
um worryingly
um among other things uh hereditary
party by the way american politics
uh is does have this tendency in it in
both major parties but uh
the the prospect of the of being offered
another member of the bush family
even for those of us who thought there
were things that george w bush and
george h.w bush did that were
laudable
great about this family they have to
provide a quarter of american presidents
in the last half a century you know i
mean
it's if these questions hovered um as
you could say they did to some extent in
democratic politics with the kennedys
this evening you know you could say that
with clinton's and more um
but it's it's obviously a tendency uh
the the the republican party i think by
2016
did look like it was perfectly happy yet
again to sort of shoo in
somebody from a relatively small number
of
um of candidates relatively small number
of families who might fit the bill
and uh and then along comes donald trump
and yes i mean famously sort of insults
and abuses and amuses his way
uh to the top of the ticket and uh
i i think there's a lot to be you know
still gone over about that there's
there's
an awful lot that's been said about it
um
but yes i mean when it's quite hard i
think for non-americans
to to recognize that the the level of
distrust and indeed contempt
that is felt towards washington from
outside the political beltway uh the
only thing i can think of as being
analogous to it in
uk is the way in which nicholas sturgeon
and other national populists in scotland
talk about westminster you know as if
everything at westminster
is uniquely terrible and everything that
comes out from it you know and this is
the way in which people
uh both sides of the island america but
particularly america's side
uh have the republican side have talked
about washington
um and yes i think that to that extent
and this youth candidate came along and
sort of said to hell with them all
had something going for him one of the
obvious things from very early on was
that whatever donald trump
said what he actually managed to follow
through on
was tiny in proportion to the claims he
made
you know i mean he that that
that have again it's about magnanimity
and victory probably shouldn't have said
the other day that
trump was the most disastrous i think he
said incompetent president in american
history
um again i mean i'm not sure it's it's
certainly true that to a great extent
donald trump when he had the levers of
power
and this was one of the main critiques
of him from the right had
so i knew absolutely no idea
of how to control the dashboard as a
whole
and and and yes and to that extent and
that was one of the reasons why he lost
quite a lot of his supporters on the
right
and douglas we've seen his actions we've
seen the speeches
how much do you think his actions and
his speeches have undermined american
democracy
um i think we have to be very careful to
avoid overstatement on this
you know um to one extent it's you know
the whole thing is
is uh is an enormous embarrassment
for american for friends of america and
i think what's more that uh
uh there is a lot to pick over and that
should be picked over and what led
to the events uh the capital on
the 6th of january that said uh
i do also think it's important that
people don't play
up things like saying this shows that
america
isn't a democracy or anything like this
i think there's a lot of
chatter like that which i i can't help
again i restate the extent to which the
um the organs of american democracy
succeeded and worked in recent months
you know the the stress test
uh um has been all
most inauguration but the stress test
has been
almost completed and american democracy
passed it
uh i referred in a column a couple days
ago to the fact that when i was in
central eastern europe recently
uh i was
worried
going around but um i joked me going
around that part of the world and russia
that
uh the problem with america was that he
had spent so much time exporting
democracy in years
in recent years it forgot to keep any
for itself at home
but i i worry about those sort of things
because i worry about what people who
would make those sorts of jokes would be
hoping
to get you know um
we've seen in recent days uh uh
president erdogan of turkey condemning
the scenes on the capitol head
this is this is a man who uh
12 hours after a possible alleged coup
against him
happened to have the names of 2 000
judges to hand
to make sure he got rid of so we won't
be hearing lessons
in american democracy from president
erdogan thank you very much
uh the same goes the chinese communist
part
martin are careful in this america is
has been uh for many years
is a i think it remains so uh i think
that the people who would like to
overstate
event way so
demonstrate some failing in democracy or
much more are
trying to do something else or are
too pleased for my taste with what
they've seen
and what they think they can get away
with in their own countries as a result
of it
so i just
i for level heads on this as always and
i
i i i i reiterate the the maxim i've
said in recent years over so many
different things
the number one priority is do not be
driven mad
do not be driven mad and it's it's a
very good point to make i mean the
people who do seem to be driven
somewhat mad are the people celebrating
his
uh removal from twitter well let's just
uh
i want to get to the big take but i had
another question for that
politics yeah all right and maybe better
coming from you because we've we've
we've sort of asked a lot of questions
about the right the rights
responsibility but actually
uh there's a there's been a role for the
left in enabling what's happened too
um right so i guess the question that we
you know that we want to ask on on
behalf of the left is
this constant demonization of the right
this constant attacking of the right and
painting as
as if they're you know they're evil
they're you know they're wrong
they don't care about the world painting
them into a corner
didn't that just embolden people to
support trump and
people for people to think look this is
where you've put me
i'm going to behave badly because in
your eyes i'm a bad person
and also add to that of course the the
riots that we've seen
in in the whole of 2020 where uh
political violence was essentially
endorsed by the main players on the left
oh yes i mean uh um i i didn't see
condemnation
uh from anything like
that of recent days or claims that uh
everybody on
on the democrat side dial should take
equal responsibility or anything like
that
when protesters were allowed to assail
federal buildings in seattle in the
summer for instance
or have been besieging um
state property uh for months
as it happens uh so i do think there's
something in that
but again i mean i think i think people
have to avoid i've always thought
i saw it as a tendency among some trump
supporters
i think the tendency always has to be
avoided to say i'd like my enemies to
suffer
um and that seemed to be something which
had crept into american politics and
which donald trump was a sort of
answer for for a part of the right was
um
you you know look at um a famous example
of the problem was what bill maher
said ahead of trump's election in 2016
when
bill maher had the decency and the
honesty to
say who we said john mccain
was a racist and um
xenophobe when he ran for a president
in 2008 but he wasn't we were just
saying that
because we and i know we said that mitt
romney was a misogynist and a racist and
a homophobe when he ran for office
in 2012 we didn't really mean that what
we just wanted was for our
our guy to get in and and and
then he said but you see here in 2016 it
actually is
the case it actually racist and a
misogynist and a homophobe
and the thing was that a bunch of people
said
but that isn't that's something you kept
telling us
you kept telling us that all
candidates from the republican party
were racists and homophobes and
xenophobes and misogynists and hated
women and
he didn't view women as people uh these
endless endless claims like this were
made about
everybody who was running from the right
so then you get donald trump
who as i say insults his way to the top
of the ticket
and donald trump um whatever the
negative and i've said it so many times
in recent years
it was not um why america didn't know
about donald trump's character
or much more it was why they knew it
and they voted for him anyway that was
the question
for 2016 to be considered and
uh and and one of the answers of why
they did it anyway
was it and decided that donald trump
seemed to frankly to use a british ism
on it
piss off the opposition so much
that this was a kind of virtue
that the pro
is vulnerable to that tendency it's a
very ignoble tendency
it's one that it's worth avoiding uh
um this this character
really makes my opponents froth
therefore
i will the democratic process
but it's definitely there and i think
and i think that there was obviously a
huge amount of
upset and disdain and and much more on
the right
uh but you know people have to take
responsibility for their own
action absolutely and
douglas you know that we we see
you know people on the left they now
have they've got their man
and they believe that everything is over
everything is solved we're going to now
move forward
do you think that's going to be the case
is racism completely finished with joe
biden
sexism as well i mean i think
that sexism racism stuff i i really do
i'm not um i
i think that a binary had been set up in
recent years we've talked about
a bit about this before and obviously i
write about it about it a bit in the
madness of crowd
if you didn't submit to a certain type
of politics and all of the same things
and you were therefore beyond the pale
and unfortunately it left
on occasions majority populations
allegedly beyond the pale which is
obviously not a sustainable position
um and i'm
i mean we'll see but what i've heard so
far
from president-elect's office
does not suggest much in the way of
uh actual reconciliation i think
um and obviously donald trump's actions
don't i mean he's
announced that he won't go to the
inauguration which is a perhaps
characteristically an elegant and uh um
indecent thing for him to decide to do
but
um to that extent yeah there will be no
uh reconciliation from this and if i
just quickly say so one of the things
again that i i picked up from my travels
in america i was
traveling seven or eight seven or eight
states i think um
uh it was a fair-ish uh idea of what was
going on in the country
um one of the things i picked up very
strongly and i wrote about in spectator
afterwards was
my concern that america had got to this
stage not because it interpreted events
differently
but because it saw the same thing and
came to different conclusions about what
it had just seen
and i i can't stress enough the worry i
think we should all have about this and
the amount of thought that everybody
from every political side should put
into this
um there were again in 2016
very significant senior members of the
democrat party
who said that donald trump had only gone
into office because of the russians
and it was incumbent upon them to prove
that claim and they first of all claimed
that there were
um actual votes uh manipulation
and voting machine manipulation done by
the russians
and then that didn't stack up and it
went on and on down to a few russian
bots
uh um and and so they they were willing
the democrats were willing to play with
this
uh very nasty uh thing of
no we don't really accept that this is a
legitimate president they were willing
to do that in 2016.
donald trump was willing as always to go
a step further
than anyone else and in 2020 actually
says no i i didn't
lose i i won um
and and here's the thing again any
friend of america any americans should
be thinking about
the polls seem to show in recent weeks
nine out of ten trump voters
agree with the president's claim that he
won the election
but that's a disaster and you've got to
find a way to mend that
um the the great one of the great
geniuses of the democratic system is not
just
that it allows the victor to know that
they have won
but it allows the loser to know that
they've lost
and i said quite often in recent years
if the democrats had actually spent four
years trying to work out
why donald trump had won in 2016
they could have done an awful lot of
good for their own party as well as for
the country
if they hadn't have spent their time and
wasted their time on
russia conspiracies and much more and
just work out as i say
why the american people knew what they
knew about donald trump and voted for
him anyway in 2016 in such large numbers
that's the task worth have worth
immersing yourself in but here's the
kicker to it
is that that is also something that the
republican
right in america is going to have to do
now and my worry
is that donald trump has led them and
misled them
in such a strong way that they aren't
again
like the democrats like so many of the
democrats after 2016 they're not going
to work out why they lost and they
haven't just lost the presidency
they've lost the senate they've lost the
congress it's their worst case scenario
and that should be
when you've lost as the republicans have
should be the moment when you start
start to work out why you have lost
and the problem if the if so many
republicans don't think they did lose
is that again they will waste their time
and they will waste everybody else's
time
not mending things they could and should
mend because they haven't got through
the first
stage of accepting
the reality and that's that's one of the
many things about this that worries me
we've seen the left um spiral
into conspiracy theory and much more
and violence and routine violence and
much more
and i would not be at all surprised if
uh uh this motif of the vote having been
stolen
and it's everyone against the people
and all this i wouldn't be at all
surprised if we don't see a degeneration
on the right that mirrors the
degeneration that's happened in recent
years on the left i think it's a
source of enormous concern
uh douglas i know francis you're keen to
get to the twitter point and that's
super important for us to talk about but
let me ask you about this because
you you talk about the republicans
working out why they've lost
uh and as you know some republicans made
the claim that it was venezuelans that
interfered so
between the two of us we've basically
been responsible for the last two
elections in america yeah uh a dead
venezuelan leader that was that
yes that was one of the least portable
claims
in the grave venezuelans can achieve
these things yeah
absolutely but but i would argue and i
and i i don't think
it's it's unreasonable to do so that had
it not been for the coronavirus
donald trump would still be present and
if you
take that into consideration while i
agree with you it's important for the
right to work out why the
where the right lost on this occasion
and lost as you say spectacularly
i also think the abide in victory is
paping
papering over not just cracks but chasms
that are existent in the left
uh and i frankly i would say they got
once in a century lucky
and i mean how are they going to deal
with with that
yeah that that that's this is a very
important area this
um i i do think that the the left
america will see this as a as a
apartheid else because of events of
recent days we'll see this is a total
vindication
of everything they claimed uh they you
can already see it in this sort of
uh stop fascism uh uh sort of stuff
um they really are to dig down on this
that that uh
2021 was actually the year they they
were personally like
uh french resistance fighters in uh in
the 1940s and you know
uh um i think that there's enormous uh
amount of hubris that will be
uh occurring at the moment and as you
say
we come back to this this this question
of in a way
what the trajectory might have been if
2020 had been like a normal year
um somebody fairly close to the trump
team said to me a couple years ago i
interviewed them uh that there were only
two things they needed
that that were really needed for donald
trump to be re-elected
this was about 18 months ahead of the
election uh there are only two things
really that
were needed one was um that
the president that the economy needed to
keep growing in america
and the second was and the president
must get us into any unwind
noble foreigner he seems to be if that
was true and i think it is
there was certainly a serious ring of
truth about it if that was the case
you know employment kept growing uh
american public kept feeding the the the
um
of the president um and
some happy luck as well then then he
could
float back into office i think that was
certainly possible i i thought
quite frequently uh in 2020 uh that that
was
the case uh and uh of course you know by
the time he went to the poll
it was disastrous here for all of our
economies
where public borrowing state borrowing
went
soaring up gdp crashed the
economy was basically shut down
it was hard for any president to return
to the
public that that famous crucial question
you know
are you better off than you were four
years ago um
you know it doesn't really matter if the
answer is
we'll know but that's partly because or
largely because of a
virus that that came from wohan and
uh has shut down the economies of every
major country in the world
it it didn't really matter if that was
the uh
there's a sort of small print when
the main thing is no i'm not better off
now
than i was four years ago uh
i can't leave my house i've lost my job
uh i've got a one thousand dollar check
from the government that's meant to see
me through months
um uh i i can't uh socialize
and much more i mean it's not it's not
an optimal situation to go back to the
public in is it
and um and so yeah i'm i'm sure
but by the way i mean we also see in
this the roots of some of what the trump
uh team might be trying to do in the
coming months and years which is
as to claim that only if it only hadn't
been for the virus he'd be back in
um and whilst i think it's obviously a
factor i think
it would be a mistake to focus only on
that because i think they should also
focus on the many other things that
we could all reel off in our sleep
of the negative things about donald
trump that would mean the american voter
might not vote for him
i mean by the way so i still find the
most interesting stat on it
uh um raise in um
uh republican under trump but the fall
off
of white males voting republican under
trump
which tells you exactly the opposite
thing from the thing that the left would
like to pretend
about the trump years but as i say yes i
think i think i think it would be a
mistake because it might let team trump
off
other parts of the self-examination they
in the gop will need
isn't a real problem as well the fact
that biden isn't going to address
the problems that the trump base want
addressed
he's he you know he's a neo-liberal he's
more of the same he's in the hillary
clinton mold
it's not going to address america's
problems
no maybe no individual can though
um i mean maybe that's something that
that um
sort of rely on a figure that
combines the moral and virtues of
martin luther king winston churchill and
you know and on and on i mean
it's it it may not be the right
perception that you've got to wait
around for that person to come
long the reforms that are needed are
literally in the hearts of every
american rather than
in one person who has the fortune to be
in the oval office
i think there's an enormous amount of
criticism that can be made of biden
it's that there was going to be
something he would achieve in his sixth
dec
achieved in the previous half century um
i think that's certainly a problem but
in a way again
maybe that was one of the reasons why
people voted for him as peggy noonan
said in the wall street journal ahead of
the election
after the corona week when the president
got corona
and they sort of saw biden as uh as
normal and that's a that's a perfectly i
mean
it's a perfectly reasonable instinct
uh but i agree with you i think that
there are i think there are serious
in i i would put it this way there are
serious interpretation of the world
and interpretation of america questions
which i don't see joe biden and kamala
harris addressing
um and i think i think
if i can say so one of them is the same
one we're all struggling with in our
countries which is
um the extent to which people have the
right to be
basically proud of their past of their
country of its achievements
and um and not want to change it too
much
i mean it basically comes down to that
for a lot of
small c conservatives it's just they
they like they love their country think
it's a force for good in the world
uh broadly speaking this this speaks to
patriotism almost everywhere and
um broadly speaking you think your
country has been a force for good
you you love it you like it you'd like
it to continue
and continue in the way it has been uh
with small modifications but nothing
vast and i think a lot of americans in
recent years have seen a part of the
left-wing project which is fundamentally
rewriting american history
which is rewriting it in a totally
negative light
which seems to have very big plans for
the country that
uh do not seem to have the endorsement
of the majority of the population
but seem seem to really know what they
want to do and and and this worries
people and
and and i i i personally think it's a
perfectly reasonable instinct to be
worried when
when the the when people come along
with a very clear project that would
fundamentally change
part of the nature of a country which
you like um
now i think that it's been over egged
deeply deeply over egg particularly by
trump
the extent to which the american left
does plan uh
to change this the the rally of uh
trump's i reported from pensacola
florida
in late october uh you know i mean he
said
he said to the crowd there you know if
the democrats get in you know
you won't have your guns that's very
contestable
i mean obviously the worst thing that
can happen is for a person
who's british to talk about america's
second amendment
but um i that the democrats may
change some of the laws around it but
the idea that they will disarm the
citizenry seems to me highly implausible
uh much more implausible was trump's
claim that
that if the democrats get in you won't
be allowed your religion
i i couldn't ever see how that was
a reasonable interpretation of democrat
policy
so it can be overedged and had been
overrated particularly by trump for
obvious
electoral reasons um but
but yes i i i think i think one of the
central points come back to is this
is this question of um just
decent reasonable people who are
patriotic
think their country country's forces of
good in the world don't want it very
dramatically
changed and should not
in that process be decried as racists
homophobes sexist misogynists
and all the rest of it and i think those
people have been
very freely insulted they have been
one of the only groups you're allowed to
completely freely insult
in society and this
point is either a point where that could
start to mend
or it could be the point where everybody
digs down where the people who claim
that everybody who's ever voted
republican in america
is a misogynistic homophobic racist
sexist
fascist who wants to storm the capital
uh
they they there will be people who will
double down on that claim
and there will be republicans uh trump
uh
supporters who will be who will be more
and more embittered
by the total lack of sympathy
for their concerns and
reasonable concerns at that and will
double down in ways of their own which
we can only at present imagine
so how do we bridge this divide than
douglas because as mentioned before i
don't think joe biden is the man to do
that he's not the man to unite america
well he has to be i mean it comes out
that he he has to
try he and vice president let harris
have to try and i just i hope they do i
did suggest
immediately after the election that the
world really let alone america
couldn't really cope with having
election after election which the
results weren't agreed upon
yeah and that one very good place to
start to heal
to stop this thing i describe of the um
seeing the same event but coming away
believing you've seen different things
a very good way to deal with that would
be i said whoever
wins the presidency to set up a
commission
of inquiry into uh electoral practice in
america including mail in ballots
and i don't know exactly how you would
do it you'd have to have
eminently non-partisan figures uh
respected
individuals i can think of very many in
america
of left and right as it happens i don't
think there's a shortage of them
i i think it'd be i think it would be
incumbent upon anyone who cares about
the democratic process in america
to to do something like that get a group
of people together
to look at how we can make sure that
next time there is an election in the
united states of america the world's
leading democracy the most powerful and
important nation on earth
that next time there is an election the
winners know that they've won and the
losers know they've lost
and if that happens if if america could
just agree on
one thing like the outcome of an
election
once that would be a start
otherwise it is just the thing of
running down your own
your own rabbit hole your own
interpretation of events
well speaking of running down rabbit
holes francis has been trying to get
this question in for about 30 minutes
so why don't we get to it and you know
you talked earlier in the interview
about
not becoming overly dramatic about
events
not talking about the end of democracy
but
i will put it to you douglas i will put
this to you because it's how i feel
that what we have seen in the last 24
hours
with not donald trump being suspended
for a particular tweet
unless he deletes it but actually being
permanently
removed from the main way that he used
to communicate with the public
uh followed by tens of thousands of
accounts being removed you and i
and francis and all the rest of us have
seen this happening right
uh this big tech censorship
now represents i don't personally
believe
if this continues we're ever going to
have a free or fair
election ever again and if that is the
case that is the end of democracy would
you agree with that would you disagree
with that
i don't think it's the end of democracy
but i think we have to
start to speak very plainly about big
tech
i think uh big tech is the enemy
of free expression free inquiry free
thought
and yes possibly at some level of
democracy itself
i've actually written about this for the
mail on sunday tomorrow uh
this in recent years the more that i've
immersed myself in learning what
what exactly it is that silicon valley
is doing
let's be under no pretense about this
donald trump would not be president were
it not for twitter
[Music]
donald trump because it's had its use
of him yeah
here we get to the absolutely
foundational truth i think all of us
have
to say more often even when
we already know it and that is this
the
business involves the total hollowing
out of every other institution
in society other than themselves they
feed off the entire corpse
eat the whole thing for their own
enrichment
and then move on they've done it with
everything
every is now helping
these big tech companies and the big
tech
companies are using them it happened
with all sorts it happened with
musicians
it happened with writers it
happened with jitter after sex and
people just sort of
said well we've got a who accepted it
seneca has done to journalism
i mean it's hollowed it out
i mean thank goodness there are still
some papers but look at who wins the war
each time it comes on now
there was a period where the papers
thought that it was useful to have
big tech to increase their own platforms
but look at what happens like ahead of
the us election
uh in november when when the new york
post
america's oldest among the most
vulnerable in uh
media institutions has its twitter and
and uh facebook accounts suspended
because it runs a story that is negative
about joe biden and the companies by
then decide they want biden to win
that is that was an astonishing
dangerous standoff
and that america's oldest newspaper
could be silenced by the
big tech was one of the many many signs
we've had
that something very dangerous was going
on that the
the um the financial model of big tech
has always been that it relies
on the citizenry to correct
each other's behavior or attempt to
correct each other's behavior
for free in their spare time
and this enriches the platforms this
enriches twitter this enriches google
this enriches facebook and so on
and we've known that this was the model
for a long time and
the question has been well how how how
do we avoid it
i mean we're on one such platform at the
moment
you and i we all know
the extent to which youtube is a totally
dishonest player in this that it doesn't
it pretends to be one thing and is
another just like twitter
just like facebook just like google
whenever
youtube is caught for instance as it did
recently um
taking down talk radio's channel in the
uk
because some talk radio presenters had
been
questioning government lockdown policy
i mean again you've either got a free
society or you haven't and
in a free society if the citizenry are
all locked in their houses
and then are told they can't even talk
about it you're in trouble
aren't you um but here is youtube taking
it upon itself
to take down talk radio's channel
because of that
and then once there is the brouhaha
youtube does the usual thing of
pretending that it was all a mistake
it's what it always does when it's
caught out so what it always does when
it's caught out it's the same with
twitter
look at the extraordinary evil of
twitter as a platform
i i i can do it at the moment as can you
we you should just check
whether ayatollah khamenei's
count yeah the ayatollah is still on
twitter
the amaya toller is still on twitter
he's got very progressive views douglas
in israel absolutely yeah yeah all this
all those people
all those people who spent recent years
trying to pretend that donald trump was
an anti-semite of all the things you
could say about him
that he was an anti-semite here is a man
khamenei who has repeatedly called for
the total eradication of the jewish
state
fine with twitter fine with twitter no
problem
uh the communist party of china's
twitter accounts are they still up we
can check
now yep
yep the communist party of china is
still going strong on twitter
uh president of the united states not
allowed
communist party of china tick
verification
well hold on well let me push back on
that then so you've i've just asked you
if this is end of democracy you've said
no it's not and then proceeded to give
me about
20 reasons why i would argue it is so
what are you seeing that i'm not seeing
i'm i'm saying that i don't think we're
there yet i think we're in a very very
dangerous position i don't think we're
there yet
but the platforms just
certainly of these platforms in recent
years and this is it's been such
a difficult we've all seen it ourselves
i think everybody
but with the platforms um for instance
uh oh you know twitter or something
decides
to uh chuck off some
sort of right one really minds all that
much because they don't much like the
person
and they've said some stupid things and
some wicked things over the years and so
so everyone sort of just goes along with
it but
before you know it here in 2021 where
the
the outgoing president the united states
is now in that group as well
and i i've pointed this out for some
years but
one of my favorite examples of the
malevolence of the platform of twitter
was at the same time it was making a
huge
show of its bravery
in i think maybe it was katie hopkins or
something had been
chucked off the platform they there was
still twitter accounts for lash curry
tiger
the terrorist group who carried out the
mumbai massacre in 2008.
lashkar-e-taibo were happily tweeting
away
jack dorsey had no problem with
lashkar-e-taiba so you will you come
back to this question is do they not
have a problem with it
or do they not know are they ignorant or
are they malevolent
uh and i think that there's a bit of
both going on
you know when the tech companies started
they didn't know they were going to be
in the position that we are all in now
i think they didn't know uh uh
conversations i've had
people at google facebook twitter and
elsewhere suggest this that you know
they end up with a tool that makes
gutenberg
look small
and they end up having to confront the
questions that grown-ups
in the free press apart from anything
else and which by the way always gets a
terrible ride
everyone loves to attack the free press
the newspapers proprietors
writers editorials and so on but the
free press
had been thinking about all of the
questions that twitter and facebook have
been
fumbling over for centuries
this is so watching watching the tech
platforms struggle with this is not just
like well it was originally it was just
like watching the slowest kid in the
class
but increasingly it's become something
else
i said somewhere that
that watching watching twitter and
google and facebook and
youtube talking about free speech
was to steal a quote from evil in war
like watching a severe vars in the hands
of a chimpanzee
they don't they just no idea what
they're dealing with they talk about
free speech and they've no idea what
this thing is
and they're all starting from scratch
and
in america of course after 2016 the tech
platforms were flooded with
obama and ex-ex of armor appointees
and then of course when nick clegg loses
his seat in 2017 he goes into the senior
position of facebook
and drags a load of unemployable lib
dems in his wake
uh into the uh otherwise unemployable
lib dems i should say in his wake
so that these people are now deciding
what you and i
and everyone else in the world can know
and
hear and say and they are
at the very least not up to the job
at the very least not up to the job
but in actual fact are also constantly
demonstrating themselves as were the
examples i just gave to be malevolent
actors
you've seen the tweets that the chinese
communist party sent out this week about
re-indoctrination of uighur women i mean
this is this is properly
propaganda that twitter allows
to go out and i i worry as i know both
of you do and i know all of
the people with us at the moment do i
worry deeply about this not least
because
of the highly unusual situation we are
in in regards to corona
and lockdowns and much more and
the attempts by the platforms to
as as if they're starting free speech
101
course in their first semester you know
at the
third rate university you know they are
to watch that being done at this time in
our history with the amount of brewing
discontent there is is is deeply deeply
troubling
and douglas you've explained it all very
very very very well as is as
as is your style but why is it that more
people don't
understand this why don't people get it
i try and explain to my friends who are
very intelligent people very good
careers you know go to good universities
and you explain this to them they say
well no one's got the right to a twitter
account what's your problem he was
behaving like an idiot he got kicked off
twitter grow up
yeah um well a lot of people don't know
the extent to which they are being
manipulated by the platforms and i think
that that is
i think that is something you just
have to hope person by person changes i
mean
take any of the the the um news uh
feeds that come up with the various
platforms like google
um what what comes up on google news
what comes up on yahoo news
um it's the same weird outlets it's
a mixture of grievance mongering
far left wingery and hello magazine
so people have to just sign out of that
they have to i'm not i'm not having
that's not
that's not the world i'm going to live
in i'm not going to be force-fed
um like some chimp i'm not going to be
i'm not going to be misled like this i'm
not going to have my life
derailed like this um
you know the who is it the contest
valet was said to have been uh asked to
wake him up every morning with the
with the call what was it uh a rise
uh you have great things to achieve
today
um i don't think everyone can be woken
up with that
we we all have great things we can
achieve in our lives
and the tech platforms have decided to
feed us pap
total pap and they hope that it'll
satisfy us
and unfortunately they've got away with
it for a very long time
and they've even got away with using our
rage
yeah sorry douglas to jump in uh i want
to come back to the tech
uh issue but we've done about an hour
and i want to get to everybody's
questions so
uh we uh really appreciate your time
guys so stick around
we'll be back in a couple of minutes and
we have uh a thank you to say to
all the people who make the show
possible so we'll see in a couple of
minutes with questions
send yours now using a super chat on
paypal and we'll get to them straight
after this
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that sometimes you're abroad you
don't speak the local language it's very
awkward like france is talking to a
woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and
easy to use interface they have daily 10
to 15 minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up
or maybe you're just english right now
babel is offering
our fans six months free on a six-month
subscription
with babel using our special code which
is of course
trigger that's babble b a b
b e l dot co dot u k
slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel i did
but seriously go to babel dot co dot uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
do you want to spice up your life yeah
well in that case i have just the
product for you
it's screaming chimp chili sauce made
from fresh chilies they're a british
company based in durham that create
beautiful chili sauces that are vegan
friendly
gluten-free and free of the 14 main
allergens
they're for [ __ ]
joking aside they have a whole range of
flavors all the way from mild
to wild for real men i'm a real man
they've got a range of unique and
classic flavors they've got pineapple
mango and papaya chimpotley excellent
pun and
original hot sauce go to
screamingchimp.com that's
screamingchimp.com
and spice up your winter do you have a
website
or do you plan to have a website well if
you do
then easy dns are the company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be cancel culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns of rock
solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get fifty percent off with the
initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy
that tells you everything you need to
know about technology
privacy and censorship
welcome back everybody i hope you
enjoyed a continuous stream of us
selling you stuff
that is it for the adverts we're gonna
get douglas back on here we've got so
many questions to talk about
douglas i am uh ashamed to have had you
watch that but nonetheless it was
necessary
it was a great pleasure
[Laughter]
listen before we get to we've got a
question from hannah here which i really
appreciate and i want to get
to i actually wanted to ask you and it's
very unusual both for us and for you to
talk about individuals but
such as his caliber i would say and
uh the relevance to the conversation we
were having just before we finished the
interview that i do want to bring it up
what did you make of sam harris and his
uh quite continuous demand for donald
trump to be banned from twitter
and yesterday thanking jack dorsey for
doing that
i always imagined that sam would be very
much on the freedom of speech side of
things
uh so i was very surprised what what do
you make of that
um sam's a friend
uh his views on trump are very well
known
he's made no secret of them uh i just
myself would say that
i think it's i still think it's the
wrong decision for twitter
uh i think that it
is what's more i have pathetic
timing for them i mean i mean it's just
it's
it's amazing that and i i think there
are no thanks
that should be given or need to be given
to
jack dorsey for
for dumping the person he created after
he's been of use to him and his platform
and his money-making machine
uh fair enough i just disagree with sam
on that but uh
um you know i might in my experience you
can have an awful lot of disagreement
with people and still be friends and um
absolutely uh hannah uh says douglas do
you think the uk
or the us will reach a breaking point
with draconian covert 19 measures
and begin not complying in 2021
she says in my opinion we can win by
peaceful non-compliance when people wake
up to the show
and social engineering is afoot what are
your thoughts
well i don't i don't agree that it's
simply social engineering i think the
virus is a real thing and people should
take it seriously
and uh should be very careful and
cautious
uh i think that there has been
throughout the whole of this period
a very difficult uh balance which we by
no means have always got right
and that balance is between public
health and the economy
and the public health has been given
priority
consistently and the economy has been
put into a second order of priority
and at some point
that is i think with the vaccine new
news it seems others that that
we get out of this and are able to sort
of get back to normal life
um by the summer
and that the economic hit we take is is
is able to be managed almost certainly
just by
means of inflation and and and and
and this is a sort of bad like a bad
dream with a year or so
i don't know if that'll be the case um
i've been
rather
surprised how planned in a way the
publics have been how how
um
is is a less loaded term they have been
of the advice
um but i'm i think i said to you at the
beginning of the
whole virus when we spoke i i am worried
one of which is that science is perhaps
the last remaining magisterium in us
and that seems to be fracturing and
splintering
seems to have been last year as people
have have questioned elements of the
science and particularly
have been questioning whether the
scientists should have precedence over
the economists to put it
in in one format i think
the i'm not one of those who think that
the government is going to is so i don't
think that boris johnson is secretly
using the virus in order to
i think there will be examples of that i
think there will be politicians and
public sector workers and others he'll
be very happy with the powers that have
accrued
govern governor cuomo in new york
strikes me as one such
candidate one such character who rather
enjoys the extraordinary newfound powers
he has
um my deeper worry in a way
is the question that remains after this
which is
this virus could have been an awful lot
worse
it isn't as bad i think as we thought it
was at the very beginning
it's the third such virus that has come
out of china in just over a decade
and i don't think that there is any
significant likelihood that it's not
going to happen again quite soon
because i don't forget sorry to harp on
about this but the chinese communist
party
who i hold totally responsible for this
knew what was happening
knew about the virus and didn't tell the
rest of the world by contrast the
british government the other week
when it thought they'd found a new
strain immediately announced it to the
world did exactly the right thing
paid a certain price eu countries and
others shut their borders to the uk for
a period
um but that was the responsible thing to
do chinese communist authorities didn't
do that
and what's more have just again last
week zanzana a a a
female chinese journalist was in prison
for five years for investigating the
sources of the virus
um so they're going to keep doing that
so
if we've had the year we've just had
what is the chance that it isn't going
to happen again quite soon
and the precedent has now been set that
once a virus that is
that is deadly to a certain portion of
people albeit
not to to the vast majority of people
what's what are the child what are the
chances
that the next time any virus comes out
we aren't going to have the calls to do
this all again
this is why i'm i'm not a skeptic on it
i am
deeply troubled by the lack of attention
to the fact that the economy cannot
cope with being put through strictures
like this again and again
we've admiserated whole sectors of the
economy and and my concern is that we
have set a precedent
which means next time that there is
something like this we'll do it again
and we can't afford to and at some point
the economics simply assert themselves
and douglas that rather nicely leads us
on to a question
with feinstein you've answered two of
the questions but the third part of
their question
was uh will do you think china will be
held accountable for this
no not at all no not at all excellent
um uh i mean with our
our friends in australia and the
australian government
uh um asking for an official inquiry
into the source of the virus some months
ago immediately led
to in the most insulting strictures from
the chinese authorities
um immediate uh
backlash from the chinese government
investment in australia
and and more we've seen we saw that in
the uk
we saw that in the uk what seven eight
years ago in the dalai lama affair
the david cameron government david
cameron met the dalai lama pissed off
the chinese authorities obviously by
doing so
meetings uh to do the uk government and
within a certain number of months i
think it was probably about six months
or so they held that
uh the british government apologized to
beijing and promised
never to meet the dalai lama again now
what that shows at a governmental level
is what we also see at the tech level
sorry to return to that but
again google
will do things to us that it won't do to
china
facebook and twitter have standards they
apply to americans
they do not apply to totalitarian
regimes
so we know what they can get away with
because we know the people in the
silicon valley who have become
rich and intend to cash out before the
consequences of this become clearer
and they have i think that
they should be held responsible of
course i think the chinese authorities
should be held responsible
of course i think we should we should
find out what happened and how this
happened and prevent it from happening
again
but i think there's zero likelihood of
it happening because
too many people have decided that
although the long-term
threat has always been chinese dominance
that it's worth sucking on that teat for
a little while
and seeing yourself through and that
in that is some nation's views some
government's views
and that is some individual's views and
some companies views
and um anyone who wants to
learn more about this i'm very strong
about what the chinese communist party
has been doing in recent decades
internationally as well as nationally
it's not
it's a very very rigorous scholarly and
factual book douglas we had
a big tech censorship moment there where
we lost you for a second
just as you made the recommendation what
is it that you recommend before i
ask you the next question it's called
the hidden hand
the hidden hand and it's on the ccp's
actions
in recent years let me ask you this it's
a very interesting question to me
because i think if you'd asked me this
10 years ago i would have laughed at
even the mere question being posed but
as you and i have discussed in the past
such as the nature of
the pipeline of ideas from the united
states to the rest of the west
i actually think this question is
becoming quite relevant which is
ollie who says is the u.s cultural
influence in the west a positive or a
negative
you know that's very interesting you say
that constantly i think my own
view on that has probably changed in
recent years as well um
uh well the thing is that
no nation's exports remain the same and
that includes no nation's cultural
exports
right um if you said we could do with
more french culture
you would have said what which aspects
exactly
are you talking about i can think of an
awful lot of good ones and i can think
of a few bad ones
i don't want the world's films to look a
lot more like french cinema
which i find fairly unwatchable myself
but
uh there are vast aspects of french
this culture and more around the world
and to be able to absorb more myself
i think it's same in american culture i
think there are periods have been
periods historically
american culture has given an enormous
amount to the world
uh i think that that um
has stopped uh i think that i think the
positive
part and i think we've been on to the
negative for some time now and then the
most
i wrote this in the new york post
actually last year um
the the the twitter censored new york
post
uh i said you know i i am others
i think i'm beginning to resent the
exporting of america's culture wars to
my own country i
i deeply resent seeing these sort of
fake
black panther figures in
britain sort of saying you know f the
police
as if there's some gangster from the
hood in brooklyn they all grew up in
wimbledon and you know
these these these th
these culture war exports from america
are really have been
very troubling and unpleasant for some
time i could do without
that but obviously that again i mean it
comes back to
which bits of the the culture um
obviously there are main good things i
think i think that
it does remain one of the most
extraordinary
uh questions and this is a very
conservative point to make but
it it it does remain one of the
extraordinary questions of
our era that the most important power in
the world
um the globally dominant
culture should have
produced so relatively little of high
quality
i think is an obvious question i mean an
art market that is dominated by jeff
coons for instance would seem to me to
demonstrate
a significant degree of cultural
degeneration
um i think you can say exactly the same
thing
in american universities
uh so significant aspects of american
culture i think
you would have to say have seriously
degenerated in our own lifetimes
um but i'm never i'm never willing to
write the whole thing off
just as i was every culture it seems to
me has something
interesting to give it's what you select
and
what you're fed is what matters
this is from dennis moore douglas
regardless or not of fraud
the changes to the election laws were of
such magnitude
that don't you agree we now have a
democratic crisis
well i think i come back to what i said
before so i'd
repeat myself but but um if if
that is the case then it must be proved
um
and i i believe me i
my inbox has had enough people sending
me what they regard as being
uh comprehensive evidence of
uh electoral fraud in the us
i simply i i ca i could immerse
myself in the whole thing i could do
what a lot of people do and cherry pick
small
circumstances and extrapolate them out
onto a national level i'm just not
willing to do that
i am willing to trust um
the supreme court and other bodies in
the united states
and um personally as i say i
again i reiterate anyone who does care
about american democracy should
certainly make sure that that
it is not the case next time that the
election is
is disputable um what happened after
florida by the way in 2000
they realized there was a big problem
and looked into it it did happen
exactly and and of course there were
many people who didn't believe that
george w
bush was a legitimate president until
the 2004 election and some not even then
and in fact
george w bush only sort of became in my
recollection
only became sort of at all
accepted as a president around the time
of
9 11 when the nations had a moment of
coming together
yeah absolutely uh and we've talked
about that early in the interview so
again uh if people want to
look at that particular aspect of the
conversation they can go back
donald jones uh is asking you to make a
prediction about the future which i know
you love doing douglas
he says what are the prospects that the
anglosphere remains intact and later
re-emerges
against the vocary and a triumph for
china here's hoping he says
what i think is possible i think
everything is possible i mean you know
as i'm rather fond of saying
um i i i don't like predicting the
future because if we'd been speaking one
year ago
i don't think any of us would have
predicted the circumstances would be in
2020
um and if you try to predict what's
happening now people would have put you
in a mental institution and probably
would have been quite right to do so
absolutely if if if if we've been
speaking in january of last year and
you've said oh well almost
everybody will spend the year forced to
remain in their houses
and be celibate if they're not in a
relationship you know that would be a
tricky one to believe uh you would
regard the person saying that as being
in the fruitcake
brigade yeah so and i take from that
uh um the necessity of a certain
humility about predicting the course of
events
and i certainly obviously as your
question
asks i certainly hope that
people are able to first of all resist
the totalitarianism
of our time wherever it comes from uh
whether it comes from the right or from
the left
uh whether it comes from tech platforms
or um you know anti-democratic
governments
obviously i hope people will resist that
and would do everything i could urge
them to do so
um i think that there is a particular
problem with the what i would
described as the disentanglement with
china
which is a very big problem and as i
said recently i'm
i'm particularly worried because china
is the only country that came out of
2020 with growth
figures reported i think they have
reported growth of i mean you can never
really believe them but
1.8 2.3 growth or something in 2020
everyone else's economy tanked in that
year so i'm worried about the fact that
china might
well does find itself in 2021 in a
buyer's market
and this this this is a temptation that
all our governments will have
and many companies will have to get out
of this which is to
basically sell to china um who can buy
uh rock bottom prices and i just
strongly urge
everyone absolutely not to allow us to
fall into that
situation uh it it is
um it is an unfashionable thing to say
but nevertheless still
true um that uh the anglosphere has
given the world
an unprecedented amount uh i make
uh no apology for saying that i think
it's demonstrable
provable and i think it would be to the
world's detriment if
the motif continued that somehow the
anglo-sphere was nothing other than a
sort of organ of racism and uh
colonialism and all of the rest of the
rewriting that everyone has done
but unfortunately for all of us a
generation of people
arguably certainly a portion of a
generation have been persuaded that the
only bad things that have ever happened
in history have come
from dead white men and that if
for instance the chinese had uh uh
discovered america
and uh um and decided to stay
that america would have had a flowering
relationship
between the incoming chinese and the
indigenous americans
and that they would have got on with
huge equanimity
and uh the presentation of all
slavery as if it was only something that
white men
engaged in and was unheard of in africa
and much more means that actually there
isn't there is a deep hostility in our
time
to the notion of the west to the notion
that the english-speaking countries gave
the world
extraordinarily important inheritances
and i think that there is a total
failure
at having a reasonable estimation
or even a fair estimation of the of the
pluses and minuses of of that whole
tradition
a tradition i would like to hold on to
and many people in our time would like
to burn down
but i'm just not among them and david
uh has asked is part of the problem due
to people losing faith in the nation's
establishments
and the political process our loyalties
becoming more personal
and tribal yes that that's
well clearly the clearly in
america this is the case and i think
it's the case
in in most of the other democracies as
well
we certainly see it in the uk uh failure
of trust in institutions
the problem is is that again people
lament the failure of trusted
institutions
and then the institutions behave in a
way that makes it perfectly obvious why
you should distrust
them um i mean there have been
look at very basic um arguments over the
last year
um look at the world health organization
we might have
we might have really hoped that the
world health organization would do what
it says on the tin would do what it had
says in the name
that it would stand above politics that
it wouldn't be able to be
infiltrated used utilized politicized by
china among others
but the more you look into it the
clearer it is that the
world health organization is not what it
says it is and the problem is that that
happens in
institution after institution and i do
think that the the problem of decrying
the
lack of belief in institutions is that
to a great extent the public
should have what i would simply describe
as a skepticism of institutions
the problem is
is when you say distrust and then then
then we
you know we do find ourselves all adrift
a very fine
definition of how a society like britain
thrives is that it thrives on
institutions that reflect the people and
people are reflected back to themselves
within the institutions
and that the courts and the education
system
and the law and parliament and
everything else is in this reciprocal
arrangement a reflective arrangement
and of course if one lets down the other
then that's also reciprocated uh
i'm i think there's an enormous
task to do in the next generation of of
actually legitimately building up trust
um of people in institutions but not
just because they're institutions but
building up the trust because the
institutions are deserving of the trust
and it's not enough to say you know
people don't trust the media if the
media doesn't earn
trust it's not enough to say people
don't trust the tech platforms if the
tech
platforms don't earn trust so it's an
enormous job
but i think it has to be done because
we're tempted at every level because
without it we are all going to be
fumbling in our solitudes through
totally different paths with totally
different
information and we
and i fear we will not be able to speak
across
across these divides it will be what i
described earlier in the
in the american case on in an
international scale
douglas speaking of divides changing
tack uh radically here and i can't tell
you why i have to ask you this question
but i do
uh one of the biggest issues that's been
dividing our chat here trigonometry for
the last few days
is what is your favorite type of biscuit
i hope i didn't sound too crazy i didn't
really like biscuits i mean
yes douglas is one of ours perfect
douglas you're on my side in this debate
i'm out
he doesn't like biscuits because he's a
little man like me now douglas
a more serious question uh richard says
as a fellow alditonian what are your
thoughts on the will nolan situation
and promises to decolonize the
curriculum i think to decolonize the
curriculum we've covered
pretty solidly already do you think
these moves are being driven by simon
henderson
or is there evidence of a broader
problem at the college
golly this is kind of inside baseball as
they say in america for some people
yeah um i was very lucky to be there
and regarded as having given me an awful
lot
and got me started in um
in many ways um
school could be as good um
and i suppose this case i mean
gave a speech as far as i could see what
he said first of all he gave it in a
in a series which was aimed at
provoking the students to
think differently about issues of the
day
as i see it what will nolan
did was to challenge the presiding
claims about
the the the one of the era which is that
you sort of that all
all sex differences can be attributed
to societal factors he i think
as far as i can see in his speech pushed
back against that and said no
they're also biological factors you know
however much sam smith wants to be a
mummy he won't be
um which is not an example nolan gave
but it's one of my favorites
uh he seemed to be just pushing back
against this rather silly
childish claim of the day that
everything in sex differences has to do
with societal factors and um
and promptly from
i think it's ridiculous pathetic much
sweden's disgrace
um i think that you know it was
all it was always my view at the
beginning of the woke thing that what
would happen
would be that it would be something
which would be
basically imbibed by second and third
rate institutions that is
the sort of
the legions would go for this because
it was an easy thing to do and that the
cleverer ones the smarter ones
would not play these games and that
i was wrong on that you know as
cambridge university and other places
have shown that
they they they're able the top
what used to be the top institutions are
capable of playing these silly games as
well
i don't think there's i think um i don't
know if stated i think in in
any educational institution loses
um its vitality
hear and discuss and
more importantly uh it significantly
loses its vitality when it doesn't allow
things that are true to be said
and that's what seems to me to be the
case with with
you say that it's you know it's a
question of intelligence for me it's
something more fundamental than that
isn't it a question of character to
stand up and say
i disagree you are wrong and you're
objectively wrong but
so for some reason we just have
introduced you know
after institution falling to this
nonsense and to piggyback on that alice
literally just asked a question saying
what is the number one thing that you
recommend
to people who are concerned about these
issues uh
you know and who want to support the
ability for free speech and free
discussion and free exchange of ideas
how do people stand up if they see
what's happening
well this is a very important question
uh and it's partly tactical one as well
as a moral one
um i i do think in
in the uk we have a particular
part of um of a problem which is that
our elite institutions
are in some way ashamed of themselves
they're in some way embarrassed by
themselves
uh they've spent some years trying not
to be
but they you see it in things like uh
the attempts
at cambridge university edinburgh
university elsewhere to audit themselves
and find out whether they
ever benefited from slavery for instance
um it seems to me that all of these
things
um start
to nibble away at their own legitimacy
maybe maybe when some of these
institutions were founded in the 15th
and 16th centuries for instance maybe
maybe their founders didn't have exactly
21st century views on certain things
how amazing would that be um and
and having done that there then becomes
this endless legitimacy problem
um i i i
i see where it comes from i simply don't
share it i think that um
i i'm i'm slightly bemused that within
my own lifetime
almost every elite institution has
become embarrassed
of its elitism because
i mean for instance the great
universities and the great schools are
meant to be great institutions
and are meant to argue for themselves on
that basis
not that they are exactly like
everything else but that they are not
and um of course when you come into the
issue of private schooling in the uk
that a particular set of landmines are
treading on
uh but as i say i think you see the same
thing in
the universities i think you see the
same thing in
vast ways in the public sector you see
it in the churches
um they seem to be embarrassed of their
own inheritance
and i would like to see people
encouraged out of that
and they obviously can be because they
were encouraged into it
it didn't it didn't come about naturally
it came about because they were they
were pushed into that
direction to be embarrassed of their
past to be embarrassed of being good
um and as for how people can resist it
uh i mean i i i have i have a very
straightforward one
you may have heard me say before which
is just
begin by standing up for your friends
that's just the very first one when it
happens to somebody close to you when
somebody close to you is misrepresented
um stand up for them i don't know what
the situation is among other teachers
have eaten but there will no wonder
i'd like to think that lots of other
teachers um
made their voices heard about this
perhaps they did perhaps they didn't i
don't know enough about it actually to
my shame
uh but i know for instance with brett
with brett weinstein
i know that no colleague of his at
evergreen stood up for him when he and
his wife were produced
and i see this ever i think that one of
the things we are all struggling with at
the moment is that
it comes back to the tech conversation
there are versions of ourselves that
have been
put out online by people that are
totally misrepresenting
i think that if you when any of our our
all of these
pages like wikipedia and these awful
wicked money-making companies that
pretend to be so virtuous if you went to
any of our pages you'd find that total
misrepresentations of us
deeply misrepresent our lives and these
companies get away with it
and they monetize on the back of it and
ask you to give them money to
misrepresent you
and um i think that in every little way
possible
people should resist this wrong
interpretation of people that is going
on all the time around us uh
that's just one way but there's as i
said it begins with standing up for your
friends
never let the mob take one of your mates
out uh and this
is a question from thomas sheldon uh how
do you think it is that labour if
elected
would fight against crt cancel culture
and other systems or symptoms sorry of
woke ideology
how do you much do you think kirstama
gets it
on these issues i i
just don't know i don't know kirsten
i've never met him and uh my observation
is that he would simply do whatever was
politically expedient
um if he thought that he would
win some political points by imbibing
vast amounts of critical race theory
he'd do it if he thought not he probably
wouldn't either he would obviously tend
towards
favoring that sort of ideology i mean he
obviously was one of those politicians
in the summer of last year who thought
that
he needed to so-called take the knee um
so he obviously
favors that sort of gesture um
politics but uh i i think well he does
certainly doesn't have any likelihood of
being in office for at least four years
so
it's sort of a long way down the road
question
uh douglas we have we'll do another 10
minutes if that's good with you yeah
yeah uh
we have a question from our regular
viewers called akeel bryan who says what
do you think
the potential effects of a trump owned
social media platform might be and this
is something that has been
uh touted by very serious people that we
know personally who understand some of
these things so it's not
an out it's not uh completely outside of
the realms of possibility
do you agree that anything of that
nature would would deepen uh
polarization well obviously it would
um i think it is quite likely i uh
um people were talking about it in dc
in december
before and as being one of the things
that obvious things that trump would do
and the fact that fox and trump sort of
fell out before the election
made there basically made there be a
larger
more obvious um monetization
opportunity for trump and i i certainly
worried in
recent months that that what trump has
been doing in denying that he lost the
election
is building the base for trump tv
and i think i think that's very likely
to be what he does
of counter would be but the polarization
is already there
i mean um
and i just see no in america i see no
desire on either side
to change that because both sides can
point to the other and say look what
they've done
look what they've done to us and as i
say i go back to the thing i said the
beginning
and let's make them suffer let's own the
libs
let's you know that that instinct
and so it's in a way as i say it's no
good
worrying about the polarization the
polarization is here
the question is how how to ever begin
to to heal it and we have a question
from maf
who says the west has real problems with
a lack of quality politicians
especially when we have a media that is
deeply interested
in digging up anything and everything
from a person's history to beat them
with
how can we fix this
well um it's true that we
we don't have the best kind of
politicians we do have some good ones
i i i'm you know i i think it's very
easy to to beat up on politicians but
um there are a lot of people in public
life in all of our countries who have
actually sacrificed a fair amount
to do what they think is the right thing
and that's the case across
left and right
so i'm by no means cynical about
everybody but i do think just we have
had a caliber
a problem and there are as your question
asked there are a number of reasons for
that um
an unpopular one to say is that
um people will take what is
for some of them a financial hit by
entering politics
and that hit and this seems ridiculous
to most people of course because
the salary of an mpa is several times
that of the average salary of
the general population but um the
question for some people would be is
that
hit as it were worth it for what you
will be put
through and um
i i'm again i go back to this thing i'm
not
for waiting for the perfect person
uh i think to a great extent the public
have to we have to change our own
anticipations of what we expect from
politicians
i am i don't i don't like the assumption
that a politician has to be a saint
um um or
donald trump you might say i mean in the
way you if you if you
if you it's that old thing if you in the
same way as
if you uh don't allow people to speak
you allow the person who
gets away with saying anything um in the
same way perhaps you know you oh
you over interrogate people's lives and
you get the person who
just beyond any any shame
um again might be something we've we've
seen recently
i i i would like that to be just a more
honest conversation about a whole set of
things
that we expect from our politicians um
the media can be cruel i'm part of the
media so i know
um and some of it is warranted and some
is not
i do find it strange however i don't
just sound like a broken record on this
but
i do find it strange that there hasn't
been more interrogation of the people
with real power in our time
you know um if jack dorsey were a
backbench labour mp
you know he would have had hell by now
um
i i personally i would like to see there
being as i say a greater interrogation
of the people with serious power in our
time
again sorry to sound like a broken
record you know
it turned out as as constantine said you
know it was
it was it was twitter that was king this
week it was twitter that could decide
they would not platform the united
states of america's president
and in that scenario it is twitter that
is
the king and therefore the one that
should be interrogated
um when google decides not to host
parlor
it's it's google that needs to be
interrogated
and i i i think that desire to
interrogate
people in public life we've to a great
extent and i say this is a failing of
the media
have to a great extent being focused on
people who haven't really had much of
the power i mean look at the senate
hearings
with the the social media company uh
executives i mean
watch any of them who has the power
there but these people who fly in from
silicon valley perfectly
perfectly coached and turn off their
microphone turn it on again with perfect
poise
and perfectly evade every perfectly
ignorant question you know that
those are the people jetting in to
pretend that they're involved in the
democratic process and
gaining to appear before before the
senate
those are the people with the real power
in our time and you know and add to that
douglas
add to that the fact that uh we've seen
it with the biden incoming biden
administration but it's true of senators
as well
uh joe biden's cabinet is packed of
uh silicon valley exactly with silicon
valley executives
uh the big tech companies give huge
donations and campaign contributions
to both parties and add to that the
point that you made much more elegantly
than i could about the ignorance of the
people who are asking the questions uh
and the huge power of the people
answering them and and it's it's a
complete
uh it's a crazy thing that offers
absolutely no recourse
absolutely let me give you a quick
example but it is a very dangerous point
for me to make given that i'm an author
and that
amazon is one of the very few things
that can sell books this year
um but um i clicked on amazon's page
recently and immediately up comes an ad
about how much charity
money they've donated that year uh or
recently and
amazon has just donated x millions of
pounds
how about paying some bloody tax then
and how about that you know i mean
and case office google all of them they
all
boast to us and and as i say feed us
this pat
and hope that we won't notice um
the other things they're doing and and
so i mean we're a long way away from the
question but
i really do feel that with that that
this all wraps up into the same
problem which is that you know people
don't go into politics
be good people also don't go into
politics because they recognize to some
extent that's
not where it is i mean that's a big
worry isn't it
because of course it is where it is in
certain ways
but at the same time can you honestly
say that that an average mp has very
much power
compared to one sensor in silicon valley
no absolutely not um hana 89
has asked aoc telling her followers to
put trump enablers
on witch-hunt lists cause a ripple as
well as in regard to the worry about the
left getting power
thoughts i mean i i see aoc as a sort of
perfect creation of the trumpists
i mean she's almost perfectly made by
any trump supporter um she does
everything in exactly the right order
to whip up a rage on the right she
clearly enjoys it she's got a sort of
troll-like instinct
i'm worried about always that that
people like her do actually end up
having an over
um exaggerated clout that is given to
them by people who don't like them
um but yes i mean um she's one of quite
a number of people who've tried this
sort of stuff it's been going on in
recent days
uh um i'm always interested in the way
in which people want to attribute uh
must be held accountable for i know for
instance you know
what happened on the 6th of january you
know say
okay but if you if you play by those
rules if you play by those rules
then you've got to do the same thing in
reverse you've got to do the mirror
um you've got to blame everybody on the
other side for the riots that went on
for weeks
last year and i don't think any
reasonable person could blame all of the
democrats for the rioting that went on
in city after city last year
and then yeah so i think yes it it's but
aoc and others are i mean they're
reprehensible um you know
very ugly characters who um
oh i mean gosh if the gloves were off
you know what people like her would do
don't you right and
every stage in history there have been
people like her
um look there's somebody i won't name
but there's a british commentator who
did of the left who did it
uh before the last election um
um something again only given a platform
not because she's done any work
but because she's a loudmouth who's got
a social media following by saying
stupid things
on programs but this uh left-wing
commentator in the uk before the last
election when she was hoping jeremy
corbyn would get in
at one point you know tweeted a famous
jewish businessman in the uk saying
i can't wait to to expropriate your
stuff
and you just you think okay um
we're very lucky we live in the society
we do rather than society you'd rather
like us to live in
and i think the same when people like
aoc talk about
getting lists together of their
opponents i think the same thing i think
i'm very glad we i'm very glad america
is is in a better sense
in a better state than it might be so
that you're weird
totalitarian pornography violence
fantasies
can't be seen through can't be acted
upon
douglas we'll take one final question
this is actually for three of us so how
about francis and i answer it first and
we'll leave it's not another biscuit one
is it
no no no uh douglas i can tell you the
biscuit issued
has been settled forever you are on my
side
i win everyone in the cat loses francis
loses
there was no fraud in this election
either
so uh the question is uh he's picked
this question for me because uh this
person has a sri lankan name therefore
it's rather long
impossible to pronounce and with my
south london tones i will be outed as a
racist
when i mispronounce it so apologies at
the start
uh and this is from uh anirud
i think it is i'm uh krishna kumar
right okay you've got the easy one so
question paul three
uh what can anti-woke leftists do to
recover their respectability
as an intellectual slash political force
and the second part to the question is
what about liberals now the liberal
thing is a bit confusing given how
differently it's used in america and in
the uk
but we do have an anti-work leftist
right here right now
what does he say to this question uh i
think
always when dealing with this is to be
honest
to be true and to be
never never ever resort to the tactics
of the person attacking you as difficult
as it may seem and you have brought this
up yourself douglas is to try and meet
every one of their attacks with calmness
with truth and also as well wherever
possible to use facts
and always accept as well that their
reaction is a result
of of their own character and it's
nothing to do with you a lot of the
times people when
somebody reacts they think what did i do
but all you can really control in these
situations are your own actions
so that is where i would go with it i
think you have to destroy them with
facts and logic
no uh you know what i think you have to
do if you oppose the work stuff and you
are on the left as
i was i'm very much in the center now
but i think what you have to do
is you have to speak your mind and know
that that encourages other people
to do the same i think that's something
that we always massively underestimate
the amount of permission we give other
people by expressing our thoughts on
something
i have found that with many many people
where i've seen somebody make a comment
and douglas
would have been one of these people for
me in the past but many others say you
know what i don't agree with this and i
go oh wait
i'm actually it's actually okay to
disagree with this this
person that i like and respect with whom
i agree on many issues
is speaking up for this thing so i think
for everybody who's able to who
is in the position to uh speak up
without losing their job
uh etc i think by speaking you give
other people inspiration to do the same
and that's something you should never
underestimate douglas over to you for
the final word
yeah and i i agree with with what you
just said um
i'd add one other thing which is um
i mean the political left in um
in the west has had a very distinguished
history uh
as the political right has uh um
it's very easy to look only at the worst
people but one should also look at the
best and the best people
on the political left for instance
in the communist era the the the
anti-communists left
were absolutely crucial to
anti-communist case in the west
they could they probably couldn't have
done it on their own but they were
absolutely vital to it
and i suspect that today
um an enormous amount of the good work
the necessary work that will
need to be done the question refers to
will be done on the left and will be
people speaking uh to people i can't
reach
um who will listen to them because they
are of
the same political tribe i think that
for all of us by the way
um a great amount could be done if we
just were more honest about the nature
of
certain problems we need to address in
our societies um
as you know i've i've quite often in the
past
said that what tends to happen is we get
into discussions where there's a as it
were a good thing to say and a bad thing
to say
a thing you say to look good and the
thing that you would only say if you
were reprehensible and bad
and on issue after issue that i've
written about in my life i've kept
coming across this
and i've kept thinking why can't we have
the
debate we all actually know i mean i
literally think it in television terms
as being
the discussion you do have in the green
room or can
have in the green room but never have on
air
because you go on air and the bbc
or sky or whatever interviewer plays the
game
and the game runs
and then afterwards you have a bit of
the discussion you should have had
and the reason this happens is because
we don't
we don't concede what the what the real
discussion is and can i just very
quickly i'm conscious of the time but i
couldn't give an example
the reason that we we said last question
is we were keen
not to take up too much time but
actually before you go to where you were
going to go i wanted to
remind you because i think i heard you
once tell a story
of this very thing where you were you
were on a program debating an mp
who uh did you do do you know the one
i'm talking about where
i've debated too many mps which case
i think it was uh in the context of the
strange death of europe
uh and you were debating the issue of
islam i think
and then when you went back into the
green room an mp who'd been
you know viciously critical of you on
screen said douglas we're all with you
yeah am i remembering that correctly
yeah yeah yeah it was a
labor mp that's right i was on a program
with my friend amir tejeri
and uh yeah the mp spent all the time on
air
decrying my iranian friend amir and i
as racist fascists and uh yeah off-air
was
laudatory um um
yes and i i that's right that was an
example of what you're talking about
which is
yes but but yes because because the
thing is
is that it's i mean i said this to the
immigration debate the the
the debate about immigration is is never
honest
because you because for some reason the
system
can't allow the honest conversation you
need
and as i said in the strange death of
europe that the honest conversation
is it's a competition between competing
virtues
on that occasion i said it was between
um
justice and mercy and in the case of
the corona era i i said earlier in our
discussion i mean that
that there are competing virtues going
on effectively
the public health and the economy and
and
i mean i have heard some of that debate
but
relatively little actually i mean
almost scandalously little um
and i think i think that's odd
because we all must sense by now that
that is or should be where the debate
would be and i'm not sure why and it's
something that brett and sally and i
have discussed
quite in the past i'm not sure why all
of our systems for sense making
keep knocking us off the discussion
we should be having and instead
push us into these discussions where
which are too easy
and are not fit for purpose so that the
discussion
is um oh i see you're supporting trump
but therefore you're a fascist or
you're supporting this therefore you
support looting or
you can play it every way but what if we
agreed on what
big issues we could be addressing the
inequality one is one i've said to you i
think before
the inequality issue is like or here's
another what about what about the issue
of why
particularly now the danger that lies in
our system
with the difficulty of young people
occurring capital
that is a really really big generational
question
why don't we see it debated we don't see
it debated because what happens is
the bbc gets on a communist
and then finds you know a token
right-wing maniac
and thinks that they've solved or
they've addressed the question
and the question hasn't even been
started it's sort of been horribly
lampooned
it's been satirized it's it's a it's a
satire
what happens but what if what if we
agreed
that that is a massive problem and how
do we change it
what do we do here's another one i mean
sorry start firing them out
an hour too but earlier how are we going
to be sure that our economies don't get
out of the corona slump
by selling cheap to china
who's having the discussion it's not
happening at the white house anymore
if it if it was before i'm not sure if
it's happening in downing street
i know it's not happening on the
airwaves i know it's a subterranean
sometimes open conversation in parts of
the press
how do we how do we address that how do
we get out
what's going to happen with um with
our economies after this with a slump in
gdp
the huge soaring in borrowing that we've
seen
what i worry is happening is in the
absence of that conversation
that's where we get everyone going into
their
weird weird corners and conspiracies
it because we can't have the general
conversation and the serious debate that
we need to have about the very
very imminent and real problems we get
4chan conspiracy theories on one side
and then censor everyone conspiracies on
the other
and we're not talking about the huge
thing that's happening under our feet
you know i i i feel like
it's like being in a room full of people
all being distracted whilst the carpet
is removed
slowly from under our feet and we don't
notice
and i i
i can only say this because we can't
trust ourselves to have good faith
discussions on complex issues
and the social media companies to return
to the thing i've been harping on about
have been very happy to enrich
themselves persuading us to have
pointless rows that have only fueled
societal instability
in order to enrich themselves they are
the only people who've profited from it
and the democracies have much much been
diminished
for it and our public and political
culture have been much diminished for it
but we could find a way out and i know
because
when we've talked when brett and i have
talked on an off air when
when when good faith people i know of
the left and good faith people the right
get together and people of no political
side
if there are experts there are people
who thought deeply about things you can
solve
problems it's just that nothing in our
culture is set up to solve problems
everything again partly largely fueled
by the social media platforms
is dedicated to creating problems that
are unsolvable
and we need to find a way out of it
well douglas no one but you could have
made a more persuasive sales pitch for
trigonometry
uh so thank you for that we do try to
handle some of those conversations and
if people want to
understand why the housing market which
is one thing that we've talked about
with you in the past is such a problem
uh we interviewed liam halligan about
this very issue he's got a new book
very much addressing that issue so we
will be having these conversations
and we thank you for being part of them
well it's a great pleasure to be with
you and with all your
listeners and followers and i hope
everyone stays well
thank you very much douglas thanks
douglas we will see you soon
and for those of you watching and
listening at home thank you very much
for tuning in
yes and please remember we have episodes
going out
twice a week and live streams going out
four times a week
and these will always be at 7 p.m uk
time if
yep and if it was your first time here
hit that subscribe button if you enjoyed
the show
hit the like button and uh remember we
will see you very soon we won't be back
on there tomorrow because we've put a
couple of interviews out already we
won't be here and we'll keep you posted
on our schedule for next week take care
and subscribe with us
until we get cancelled